name a better comeback than Ponzi
schemes used to be illegal but in 2022
they're flying higher than oil prices
more common than a single guy at a board
ape convention they have exploded in
popularity especially among our ruling
class the billionaires which is why
today we are investigating yet another
billion dollar Ponzi scheme and no I'm
not talking about dokwan's terrible
decisions that's totally last month
today we're talking about
usdd that's a double d as in double the
dumb people who believe in it and like
all Ponzi schemes this one says it's
different Luna failed after it offered
20 a year and attracted billions of
dollars in Investments usdd is changing
the game by offering something different
offering double the amount of Interest
nearly 39.6 percent per year according
to their website and they claim it's
risk-free because of course they claim
that right now we've seen this movie a
thousand times but let's pretend to be a
government for a second and give this
Ponzi scheme the benefit of the doubt
how are they claiming such a high
risk-free return how is it possible and
who's behind it well it turns out to be
a billionaire named Justin Sun he's
quite the controversial figure in his
own right according to the verge he fled
multiple countries under fear of
prosecution and a former employee
alleges that they were engaged in quote
insider trading all the time which you
know in my opinion is just too much some
of the time sure who doesn't enjoy a
couple hours of insider trading but all
the time it's just greedy now when
Justin isn't allegedly insider trading
all the time he has another job which is
as an ambassador for the country of
Granada which gives him diplomatic
immunity in Switzerland which doesn't
really matter except for the fact that
it grants him the title of his
Excellency for some reason which he
really enjoys being called in interviews
you're Excellency I yeah it's kind of
crunchy but we're gonna look Beyond
Justin Sun's colorful past today and ask
the real question what is usdd all about
is it truly upon this game is it
something completely legit well Justin
admits that quote he came up with the
idea for usdd after witnessing Tara's
dramatic Ascent in other words they made
a lot of money now he wants a piece but
his timing was unfortunate he launched
usdd only a few days before Tara Luna's
collapse which obviously isn't a great
luck despite that he still wants to
convince people that his coin is going
to be different he claims that just
because one goes bad doesn't mean
they're all bad it's kind of like real
estate I believe Luna's fail it's kind
of like you know recently in China's
real estate Evergreen using too much
like Leverage uh in a very short period
of time so according to Justin UST and
Luna failed because they grew too quick
and were over leveraged and he's not
going to suffer the same mistake but
before we get into the differences we
have to address the similarities between
us Terror and usdd because there are a
lot they both claim to be algorithmic
stable coins which just means they rely
on Arbitrage to keep their value at one
dollar they both also offer insane rates
of return and both of them acknowledge
this is probably unsustainable in the
long term but that's where the
similarities stop and the differences
begin because obviously us Terror has
collapsed after accumulating billions of
dollars usdd on the other hand is much
younger only about a month old and
already has a market cap of 700 million
dollars or so additionally usdd doesn't
actually work as an algorithmic stable
coin at all yet right now the mechanism
for Arbitrage project is actually turned
off and minting new usdd is only allowed
for a small number of whitelisted
Institutions such as Alameda research
among other people now the reason this
is important is because it makes usdd
safe from the famous algorithmic death
spiral at least for now because this is
only possible when burning and minting
is active so if you're planning to short
this coin probably don't because it's
not actually an algorithmic stable coin
yet of course they claim that they will
eventually be one when they enable this
feature because of course they're not
that stable until people can Arbitrage
which is probably why they're de-pegged
from a dollar and instead trade about at
97 cents but the question this all begs
is why is this worth a dollar at all if
it's not really an algorithmic stable
coin why isn't it just worthless well
the reason for that is something called
the Tron Dow Reserve which claims to
back usdd with a bunch of crypto Assets
in fact they not only backed them they
say we've over collateralized we have
more than enough money to back up this
usdd and this is one reason they claim
they're different they're collateralized
at 300 percent and promise they're gonna
use it to defend their money they also
link the associated addresses that have
this two billion dollars worth of funds
that they say they have and if this is
all true doesn't that make usdd
intrinsically valuable if it really is
backed by all this money that's the
logic anyways I mean look at this chart
they provide they're the most backed of
any coin and some crypto YouTubers even
think it's an ultra conservative
investment people should really be
thinking of this as an ultra
conservative over collateralized
stablecoin not some risky algo Staples
so why am I telling you different why do
I think that this is ultimately a Ponzi
scheme well it's simple they're offering
forty percent a year on their website of
risk-free yield but if that's not enough
for you let's think about this for a
second they're only over collateralized
as long as this coin doesn't get super
successful because over time as more and
more people invest in it they don't just
magically get more collateral they're
collateral girl stays the same which
means that slowly by their own success
they will become under collateralized
and eventually death spiral like every
other algo stablecoin in fact if they
ever reach the success of something like
U.S Terra they would actually only have
about 10 percent collateralization now
it's here that some people might want to
stop for a second because you might say
well that's of course why Justin's son
is so careful in interviews he says that
the growth of usdd needs to be slow it
needs to be organic he's not in a big
hurry first of all we need to based on
our growth organic growth rather than a
very short period of time grows with
full average I think that that's the
first lesson but this actually doesn't
track to reality because ustd has grown
extremely fast they've grown to almost a
billion dollars in a little over a month
and it's almost all been minted
inorganically by centralized entities
remember regular people can't just print
usdd in fact one of their biggest users
is actually none other than then
Justin's son himself that's right big
shocker the main user of usdd is the
creator Justin Sun I discovered this
when I started investigating his various
wallets see he minted 40 million on
ethereum and also 40 million dollars on
the binance smart chain but it didn't
start there it originated on his home
blockchain of Tron and passed through a
bridge contract why that's important is
because we can back Trace through that
bridge contract to find out who on Tron
minted all this money when we trace it
back we get to this account which I
believe is Justin's son's Tron wallet or
at least one of them one way we can
confirm this is because this wallet is
the primary voting stakeholder on
another one of Justin Sons projects the
just Lind Dow now this is a bit of a
tangent but just Lind is a Tron lending
platform that claims to be a
decentralized autonomous organization
basically what that means is they accept
Community votes in order to decide what
to do next according to their website if
the proposal receives more more than 600
million supporting votes plus takes the
majority of votes it will be passed so
what's the catch well the wallet we just
identified is probably Justin's son they
control exactly 600 million and one
votes which basically means they can
always pass literally whatever they want
on this Dow right really decentralized
guys that's what it looks like in 2022
and you can see from their governance
page that these votes go basically
uncontested this proposal for example
has 135 votes against 600 million for
all of this means we can be pretty
confident when we say this is Justin's
son's wallet and the reason this is so
interesting is because of Justin's son's
claims that he's a big fan of
decentralization he actually says that's
the whole reason for the need of an
algorithmic stablecoin in the first
place I think while the most important
answer at least to myself for algorithm
stable plan is we basically want to make
a decision on our own Fates uh in our
own hands so basically I think these
days stablecoin is the most centralized
part of this decentralized world that's
right forget about these centralized
entities the reason we need another
algorithmic stable coin is for
decentralization but like just Lind how
decentralized is usdd really we already
know that it's tightly controlled by a
few whitelisted institutions but it gets
way worse than that because now that we
have what is nearly certainly Justin's
son's wallet we can now see how much
usdd he himself is responsible for
minting and the answer is
683 million tokens that's right ladies
and gentlemen the entire sum of tokens
they've ever minted is like 723 million
which means that Justin himself has
minted 94 of all the tokens in existence
so much for decentralized growth I guess
see it turns out this whole project is
basically just Justin's son selling to
retail Traders looking for a quick Buck
which brings me to my first theory of
what usdd might be used for not only do
I obviously think this coin is offering
unsustainable yield I think it is also a
really clever way for Justin sun to
offload Tron without affecting price
because let's think about it the wallet
we just identified controls 70 million
dollars worth of Tron but if it sold
that on the open market you're never
going to get that the price is going to
plummet right but go with me for a
second what if you could burn one dollar
of Tron and get one usdd which is how
this whole thing works incidentally and
then you sell that usdd for another coin
without affecting price like usdc so
long as you could bring in enough people
willing to buy your new token usdd by
maybe let's say offering them insane
yields you could actually cash out of
your Tron without ever affecting the
price of Tron it's one way to actualize
games without tanking your own coin
which would be pretty smart if you ask
me but I have to say this is speculation
at this point what we know for sure is
that usdd is absolutely not
decentralized 94 of it comes from one
wallet and its supposed growth hasn't
been organic at all nothing could be
further from the truth decentralization
in this case is nothing more than a
buzzword that is being used to make
people feel empowered just like Dao was
a buzzword for just lint to make people
feel a part of something that was
controlled by 600 million and one votes
I would highly recommend you guys stay
away from this coin it's a billionaire
game copied from a previous billionaires
game that crashed horrendously I mean
how much more do you really need to know
stay away from claims that say that this
is a safe or conservative bet because
that's also what they said about things
like Celsius it's literally a joke oh
and by the way there's a really funny
moment in this interview I've been
showing you that I want to play right
here it's when Justin starts talking
about this coin being backed by
liquidity listen closely I think you'll
be able to hear something in the
background uh I think in the future we
will be very careful to handle the
liquidity pool and also
um the whole market cap of the usdd just
to be clear I did not add the siren it
literally went off in the middle of
their interview anyway that's basically
it big thanks to the Twitter user defyak
for helping me with some of this
research and I want to thank all of you
for watching